la política no tiene que ser un incendio
furioso que destruye todo a su paso y
más tendremos terminada esta guerra no
cívica del rojo contra el azul bergens
blue con estas palabras el nuevo
presidente de eeuu joe biden
recalcó la importancia de la unidad
además se pronunció en contra de las
noticias falsas una de las mayores
críticas que enfrentó donald trump en su
mandato en ella es cada uno de nosotros
tiene un deber y una responsabilidad
como ciudadanos y como estadounidenses
especialmente como líderes defender la
verdad y vencer las mentiras
otro de los puntos fundamentales fue el
kobe 19 en medio de banderas para
homenajear a las más de 400.000 personas
que murieron por el virus
el nuevo presidente pidió unos segundos
de silencio para orar por quienes
fallecieron
yo les prometo esto como dice la biblia
podemos enfrentar una noche difícil pero
en la mañana vendrá la alegría
atravesaremos estos juntos
fluidez jack warner theatre
[Aplausos]
hayden también afirmó que bajo su
mandato estados unidos recuperará el
liderazgo internacional las ventas ter
eeuu ha sido puesto a prueba y hemos
salido de ella más fuertes repararemos
nuestras alianzas y nos uniremos con el
mundo de nuevo reto watch game kamala
harris hace historia como la primera
mujer vicepresidenta del país el nuevo
mandatario comparó este hecho con la
marcha de las sufragistas que en 1913
protestaron antes de la juramentación
del presidente woodrow wilson
aquí estamos donde hace 108 años en otra
posición miles de manifestantes
intentaron bloquear a las mujeres
valientes que marchaban por el derecho a
votar activo y hoy registramos el
juramento de la primera mujer en la
historia estadounidense elegida para la
oficina nacional
la vicepresidenta kamala harris no me
digan que las cosas no pueden cambiar
tras su discurso biden procede a firmar
múltiples órdenes ejecutivas con las que
comienza su mandato en la casa blanca